[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
excerpts from julia steen's latest video
[Music]
it was viewed more than 24 million times
on facebook within the span of a few
days
dean is only 23 but he's already learned
how to attract a huge internet audience
with simple magic tricks
[Music]
my dad doesn't get it it doesn't have
any form of social media so when i told
him i'm like dad my video got 50 million
views on facebook last week he's like oh
cool
uh how's how's her exams going
when i first started doing videos
[Music]
it all started two years ago dean
started making his first video clips
when he was an exchange student in
california
while his fellow students were doing
internships he was working to boost his
online presence
back home he improved his tricks
finished his course of study and devoted
himself to magic
especially popular are the videos in
which he uses tricks to grab women's
attention
his series how to impress a girl with a
magic trick has attracted almost 150
million hits
[Music]
dean performed as a magician at small
parties while still a boy
he's come a long way since then
these days he has 8 million facebook
followers see your videos man hey thanks
hi there
you are the best magician mate
today dean is on the go near his home in
east london to try out some new tricks
live
when i'm trying to create a video that
has 50 million views
you want people that are going to give
me good reactions
and usually
those types of people are people that
look confident
look friendly look approachable
[Music]
a few seconds later dean finds a good
location in front of a barber shop aside
from an audience all he needs for the
trick is a marker and some magic of
course
[Music]
boom okay x vanish
turn your hand over
what you see on the internet is a one to
five minute piece
that looks flawless but these things
take hours and hours and hours
everything from getting the right team
to getting to the right location to
learning the right tricks that can take
tens to literally hundreds of hours to
learn how long has it been since you've
lost your hair dean is known for pranks
as well as magic tricks
daddy hello who is that dad
it was dance
right
ah
even his grandmother isn't safe from
becoming a target of his jokes
with 92 million views on facebook this
clip set a record
dean is constantly monitoring what his
followers like to ensure that his next
clip goes viral too
catchy introduction
huge
snappy engaging content consistently
thumbnails
titles
not too long
it's a formula
very important to follow the formula of
how to go viral
the formula works
julius dean is the world's most
successful online magician
but he's still a long way from earning
the big bucks that the top magicians do
okay here we go three
two
one
shut the front door if you look at the
biggest magicians in the wild you've got
david copperfield who made the statue of
liberty disappear um you've got chris
angel who walked across water so i would
like to create some type of huge
publicity stunt where i do stuff that
just takes it up a level and at the
moment my magic doesn't cost very much
to make and i can only imagine
what i could make if i had huge budgets
something here we go
but in the meantime dean gets big
results from small tricks
1.4 billion views on facebook instagram
snapchat and youtube are certainly
nothing to sneeze at